it's Monday morning your alarm goes off
you pick up your phone you scan through
your emails and then you flip over your
calendar to your calendar to remind
yourself of everything you have to do
today now sometimes you have so much to
do and so many people to respond to that
you feel exhausted before you've even
gotten out of bed and it's Monday
morning have you ever met this way I
know I have it's when you've experienced
that feeling of overload when you know
you're just not going to get it all done
today so here's how I tackle days like
that I put my phone facedown on the
dresser I put on my running shoes and I
head out the door to the nearest trail
why because this is how I find solitude
and solitude is essential to thriving in
a world of overload when I am alone with
my thoughts on the trail there is no
hiding from myself there is nobody to
answer to and no other task I can be
accomplishing when I'm out running by
myself so instead I start to focus on
what really matters most to me
what is weighing most heavily on my mind
and what's driving me forward now when
I'm finished with my run I know I need
to hurry up shower and get to class but
I have found my Center for the day this
is the value of solitude when we spend
time alone engaging in something that
inspires us it allows us to reclaim an
identity that is wholly ours not
influenced or shaped by the opinions of
others or feedback or by that
ever-growing to-do list that threatens
to crowd out our space that we need to
recharge and re-energize ourselves with
the flow of our own unstructured
thoughts now I find solitude through
running
you may find it through something else
like music or art or even cooking but
whatever it is I want to talk about why
pursuing your passion in solitude is so
important to bringing your best to those
around you now let's return to campus
I'm a Business School student like many
of you and like many of you I see these
two years as an opportunity for personal
development now what that looks like is
different for everyone but at a high
level we're all here to develop as
business leaders now
Stanford's call to action for its
students is change lives change
organizations change the world that is a
bold mission so to fulfill this mission
Stanford provides us with all the
resources we could possibly ask for to
become the best leaders we can be
there's leadership coaching there are
workshops there are classes and there's
feedback feedback feedback at every step
along the way we're constantly reminded
that feedback is a gift it certainly is
but here's the catch the qualities that
make great leaders our qualities that
none of these classes and no amount of
feedback no matter how good it is can
teach us these are great tools to have
but are they alone enough to transform
us into leaders who are going to change
lives change organizations and change
the world
what about passion what about
authenticity
what about initiative the irony of a
place like Business School is that it
becomes all too easy to stop taking
initiative and start allowing our
calendars to just fill up with every
opportunity for self enrichment that
comes our way and as we put more and
more structure around our lives and we
try to process more and more feedback we
crowd out space for our own thoughts in
our efforts to become the best leaders
we can be
we can lose our Center and replace it
with a to-do list now this is when we're
in the danger zone because when we lose
our center our authenticity and our
passion qualities that do make great
leaders quickly start to slip away but
this isn't a problem that happens just a
business school this happens everywhere
I'd be willing to bet whether you're a
student or not that you feel that there
just isn't enough time in the day most
days to do everything you would like to
get done so how do we remain inspired on
a daily basis and centered we all make
trade-offs every day moments of solitude
are often the first things that we let
go of but I want to take the next few
minutes and ask you to hold on to those
moments take a step back and think about
something that you love to do alone this
is something that brings you great
personal satisfaction but it isn't
associated with any external rewards or
recognition this requires you to
completely unplug even if just for a
short amount of time so what does
unplugging mean that means putting down
your cellphone
no Facebook no texting no tweeting it
means being really alone so how often do
you unplug is it once a week is it once
a month is it never now hold that
thought and think about the last time
you did something really cool let's say
you climb to the top of a big mountain
now chances are pretty good when you got
to the top of that mountain
you wanted to snap a picture of yourself
and post it on Facebook and share with
your friends now there's nothing wrong
with that but it's worth considering how
would you have felt differently about
that experience had you never posted
that picture or even better yet if you
knew that nobody would ever find out
that you even climb
to that mountain how would that
accomplishment have felt to you then we
are so plugged in 24/7 that we often
forget the extent to which this constant
connection to our extended networks and
this pursuit of feedback and this
constant need to be checking things off
a to-do list does shape how we live our
lives and the more plugged in we are the
more we subconsciously mold our lives
and our choices to be what we want all
those people to see basically we're
living our lives on a stage but what if
the audience just disappeared how do you
view yourself in the absence of feedback
and how do you look at the world when
you aren't looking at it through someone
else's lens and what does it really feel
like to do something simply for the deep
significance it holds to you personally
when it means nothing to anyone else
that is what you learn from solitude but
let me be clear this is not a talk about
you this is a talk about how you bring
your best to those around you because
when we find ourselves just continuing
to go through the motions of life
navigating through this world of
overload that is a loss not just for
ourselves but for everyone around us I
question the wisdom that says to bring
your best to those around you you've got
to put in 110% to everything you do well
I would suggest put in 95% save that
last 5% of your energy and use it for
something that you love to do alone and
when you return to what you were doing
before your focus your energy and your
enthusiasm for the task at hand will
multiply and then you'll be able to put
in 150% so the next time you feel like
just putting your phone away
driving to the nearest hiking trail and
going for a hike or pulling out your
guitar and building out a few of your
favorite songs just do it it is not
selfish if we want to be the authentic
and inspired leaders that Stanford
Business School wants us to be we have
to remember what it feels like to be
energized to be passionate and to be
centered we have to find our Center
every day and that's not someone
something that someone else can do for
us I found my Center this morning on a
dirt trail how are you going to find
yours thank you
you